STATES, NORTH KOREA OR SOUTH
KOREA OR CHINA.
MORE LIKELY A NEUTRAL 3rd
COUNTRY.
>> Bret: THANKS.
WE HAVE BEEN DOWN THIS PATH
BEFORE WITH NORTH KOREA.
PROMISES MADE AND BROKEN.
HOPES RAISED AND DASHED.
JILLIAN TURNER HAS A HISTORY
LESSON FOR US TONIGHT.
>> ROCKET MAN IS ON A SUICIDE
MISSION FOR HIMSELF AND FOR HIS
REGIME.
>> AND PRESIDENT TRUMP FACING
KIM JONG-UN ACROSS THE
NEGOTIATION TABLE HE WILL COME
FACE-TO-FACE WITH NORTH KOREA'S
TRACK RECORD OF LYING TO THE
U.S. AND THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
KIM JONG-UN HAS BEEN STRIKE WILL
DEALS WITH THE U.S. SINCE 1994.
>> NORTH KOREA WILL FREEZE AND
DISMANTLE ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
SOUTH KOREA AND OTHER ALLIES
WILL BE BETTER PROTECTED.
>> $4 BILLION IN U.S. AIDE THAT
AGREEMENT COLLAPSEED IN 2002
WHEN PRESIDENT BUSH CONCLUDED
THE NORTH WAS NOT LIVING UP TO
HIS AGREEMENT.
>> NORTH KOREA IS ARMING WITH
MISSILES AND WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION WHILE STARVING ITS
CITIZENS.
>> LATER NORTH KOREA WITH DREW
FROM THE NON-PROLIFERATION
TREATY.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD A LOT OF
HOPE BUT CHANCE OF BRINGING THE
ROGUE REGIME BACK INTO THE FOLD
OF THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
>> NORTH KOREA CAN CHOOSE TO
CONTINUE DOWN THE LONELY ROAD OF
ISOLATION OR JOIN THE REST OF
THE WORLD.
>> BY THE END OF PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S FIRST YEAR THEY DECLARED
THEY WERE NOT BOUND BY ANY TERMS
AGREED TO IN THE PAST.